il suffit parfois de traverser le périph
pour se retrouver au chili
dans une ambiance de bodega au bar du
théâtre à l'efs à ivry la communauté se
retrouve tous les week-ends
comme d'habitude on chante on danse mais
ce soir en prime on vote vous pouvez
voter
le directeur du théâtre oscar castro a
organisé une fausse soirée électorale
comme tous ceux qui sont là il a fui la
dictature il ya 30 ans nous sommes le 16
janvier 24 heures avant les élections
présidentielles au chili c'est un
scrutin crucial la droite pourrait
revenir au pouvoir après 20 ans de
gouvernement de centre gauche mais pour
ces exilés interdiction de voter la
constitution chilienne ne le permet pas
alors ils font semblant
et je suis pour le monde est là à botter
groupé
c'est un vote groupé alors je dois te
présenter ma carte d'identité
n'ont rien tu dois juste passé dans la
cabine se crêpent tu
pourras votre secret
voilà mon vote
vous avez voté pour qui
pour enlever les moustaches imbibé de
pisco ces chiliens soutiennent tous
eduardo frei le candidat de la coalition
leur coeur est à gauche aujourd'hui ils
en rigolent
mais le lendemain c'est la douche froide
qu'elle ternit piniella était né 17
janvier ce matin les chiliens d'ivry sur
seine ont la gueule de bois sebastian
pinera le candidat de la droite est
sortie vainqueur surnommé le berlusconi
chilien multimillionnaire proprio d'une
télé privée patron d'un grand club de
foot il incarne la droite décomplexée
une exception dans le paysage d'amérique
latine sur 19 pays trois seulement ont
ni la barre à droite
au lendemain de l'élection nous
retrouvons oscars la pilule a du mal à
passer dans son pavillon de banlieue il
nous montre la une des journaux chiliens
et fermeté populi vie n'avait pas fini
avec la la misère qu'avec la pauvreté
s'ils l'ont fait c'est général je
voterai pour louer la prochaine
capable oscar ironise il est amer après
les élections il a tout de suite pensé à
son ami d'enfance michelle bachelet la
présidente sortante l'approché la plus
touchée avec michel on se connaît quand
il avait 14 ans et moi il y avait six
ans après nous on voulait faire dé
théâtre pour rencontrer les filles exact
est sept est là michel et on allait
venir de sa mine jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mais des grands sommets jusqu'à paris
les rumeurs vont vite oscar a entendu
dire que pinera ferait rentrer des
ex-membres du régime de pinochet dans
son gouvernement il appelle un ami pour
en savoir un peu plus
tu penses vraiment toi que les membres
du gouvernement de l'époque de pinochet
vont rentrer dans le nouveau
gouvernement
je pense que oui mais pas en tant que
ministre
en fait ils l'auront que des postes de
cabinets ministériels
pause car c'est incompréhensible le
changement politique ramène au pouvoir
ceux là même qui l'ont mise en prison il
y à 30 ans à l'époque il écrivait des
pièces contre la dictature une dictature
qui a fait 3000 morts dans sa propre
mère je gagne et émulsion
mamelles ma venue me voir comment
comment obama qu'est-ce que ferment
matin comme vice il est impliqué en va
de mode alors c'est le malade va
l'hôpital clinic rim café à la mémoire
impulsion d'après la nasa signer
[Musique]
depuis la fin de la dictature en 1988
oscar est partie au chili tous les ans
cette année il n'est pas sûr d'y
retourner et le vca pinera aujourd'hui
tu en tournée comme à gauche il y
a quelques jours face
à moi mais mais mais mais mais fait mal
de voir que les mêmes que
quelqu'un ne dirais pas assassiner la
maman que soient les mêmes qui après sur
le même ministre du budget il avait
dans son théâtre d'yves des oscars ne
cesse de rejouer sa vie aujourd'hui il
est en pleines répétitions d'une pièce
qu'il a écrite en 1981 quatre ans après
son arrivée à paris cela s'appelle
l'exil et mat et luna et c'est
l'histoire d'un réfugiés chiliens
échappé de la dictature aujourd'hui pour
oscar elle a encore plus de sens dans
les gradins les fantômes des généraux
qui ont assassiné sa mère ne sont jamais
très loin
en fait je suis un rôle d'un général
donc voilà qu'en général on pourrait
dire que c'est d'une certaine façon une
grande satire de pino chez moi
c'est le meilleur outil de la torture en
plus il ya un bruit assez torture
donc voilà je pense que au 7e jour
l'homme ne sera pas à pas il créa les
forces armées et de partout de surgir
colonel colonel
sur scène oscar travail avec sa fille
sur les planches comme dans la vie qu'il
partage avec elle son histoire anahi la
trentaine est partie au chili à 10 ans
pour comprendre là bas elle a découvert
le silence des chiliens face aux drames
qu'ils ont vécu le chili il ya comme des
choses
je ne peux pas de ça aussi c'est à vous
c'est comme si on voulait tourner la
page je pense que mon père c'est un des
seuls artistes au chili qui exilé mais
qu'à chaque fois qu'il revient c'est lui
qui fait tout le travail de mémoire même
si oscar ne retourne pas au chili tant
que la droite est au pouvoir ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il continuera de mener son
combat à ivry à 9000 kilomètres de son
pays
[Musique]